well John Brennan of course ran the CIA
under Barack Obama now he's a cable news
Schauder a paid analyst for MSNBC who
insults Donald Trump and advocates for
the Democratic Party Brennan no longer
works for the federal government in any
capacity he holds no official post and
yet according to two sources we spoke to
exclusively today
Brennan retains perhaps the most
valuable asset he had in government a
top-secret security clearance this
allows him to do what the rest of us
cannot do view classified government
documents and more critically discuss
classified topics with intelligence
officials still working in government
and then leaked that information to the
press this is an awesome power our
intelligence agencies keep America's
most sensitive secrets they hold highly
personal information on every American
including you it is terrifying to think
that John Brennan still has access to
any of that information Brennan is an
out of the closet extremist this week he
accused Donald Trump of treason a
death-penalty offense on Tuesday he
suggested it would be reasonable for the
intelligence agencies to conceal
information from the president that's a
violation of their Charter and a
violation of federal law on Twitter
Brennan routinely makes florid threats
addressing his tweets directly to the
president like a crazy person earlier
this year for example Brennan wrote this
quote when the full extent of your
venality moral turpitude and political
corruption becomes known you will take
your rightful place as a disgraced
demagogue and the dustbin of history
America will triumph over you you could
almost hear his finger smashing the
keyboard not a stable man Brennan is
also a passionate ideologue with a
documented history of dishonesty and not
just a little bit a lot the CIA director
he lied about spying on Senate staffers
which the CIA did and about killing
civilians with drone strikes he lied
about the steel dossier famously in 2010
he prevented the CA from referring to
Islamic militants as she hottests
because we're quoting now jihad is a
holy struggle and a legitimate tenets of
Islam this is not a man who should have
security clearance we called NBC News
today to ask if Brennan has revealed
classified information on their air or
whether he's passed that information to
his colleagues at NBC
n-b-c did not respond but brandon is not
the only reckless partisan with a
history of dishonesty who retains a
government security clearance Jim
clapper the former Director of National
Intelligence appears to have one too
same with Michael Hayden another former
CIA director Hayden recently suggested
the president is carrying out a second
Holocaust on the Mexican border in case
you're wondering how classified
information winds up in the media on a
near daily basis the New York Times
story this morning
all of it designed to undermine the
elected president and bolster the
Democratic Party now you have some sense
you hate to think the deep state is real
that there's a permanent government that
operates independently of voters and of
democracy itself but as long as guys
like this have security clearances
honestly you've got to wonder Senator
Rand Paul represents the Commonwealth of
Kentucky he is worried about this we
talked to him about it a short time ago
senator thanks for joining us sure John
Brennan is an irresponsible partisan
combatant who works for a cable news
channel and has threatened the President
on Twitter why in the world would he
have a top-secret federal security
clearance now this is alarming and if
John Brennan still has top-secret
clearance can he research Donald Trump
can he research his family can he typed
my name into computer search engines can
he look at all of my information it's
alarming if he has top-secret clearance
as unhinged as he is now calling the
president treason treasonous saying
basically that he's for you know the
death penalty for the president yeah
it's alarming if he has security
clearance it's absolutely alarming so
we've spoken to source knowledgeable
sources on this question who say he does
we tried to confirm that with the CIA
they refused to comment on it we asked
NBC his employer they refused to comment
on it
we believe it's be true what would
prevent him from speaking to current
employees of the CIA or other
intelligence agencies and getting
information keep secret information from
them that could be leaked to the press
or used against his political opponents
well you know John Brennan has a history
of leaking information already only for
political reasons but a few years ago he
linked that there was an inside
informant in Yemen while that person was
still on the inside in Yemen
he put that person's life at risk they
all backpedaled and they had to rescue
someone out of Yemen who was at the
heart of an al-qaeda you know project
trying to discover what al-qaeda's plans
were in Yemen but John Brennan leaked
their name so he's got a history of
having a problem with leaking head of
the CIA who in their right mind would
want to let him have the power still to
search through everybody's records he's
a private citizen who works for a cable
new stitch could I get a security
top-secret security clearance and find
out government secrets and use them in
the course of my job what is this I
think it's completely crazy and I think
the idea that he could be passing
secrets to the media yeah that's
alarming and then what can be done well
what we're going to do is we're going to
send a letter not only to the president
asking whether he still has clearance
which I think the president might be
interested in this issue I'm sending the
letter also to sessions and also to Dan
Coates who's over all of the
intelligence so we are going to press
the case and we're going to find out
does John Brennan still have clearance
and really should a person who has
called the president treasonous have top
secret clearance or threatened tip but
it's it's not just Brennan it is
potentially and we believe it is also
clapper Susan Rice people who are active
participants in current partisan warfare
shouldn't there be some mechanism to
prevent people who are engaged in
partisan warfare from having tough seek
and this is something I've advocated for
years and that's to have oversight of
the intelligence community by having
judges grant warrants so they would have
to go to a judge to have permission to
look at a database I don't want them
researching Donald Trump's political
supporters their records their bank
records their phone records the way to
stop it is to have an overall reform and
in fact I'm going to talk with the
president on Monday and we're gonna ask
the president will you institute a rule
a new rule at the FBI that says they
cannot search these foreign databases
for Americans material without asking a
judge for permission q for doing that
I'm sorry it's taking this long for
someone to do something about it I'm
glad you are senator thank you thank you